[Musica]
e questo in questo titolo open abbiamo
deciso di scegliere action action vuol
dire mi son dovuto andare a guardarmi
sul dizionario per essere sicuri essere
aperti a nuove idee e nuove prospettive
a rivalutare la quotidianità a guardare
le cose in modo diverso e anche
un'azione e una chiamata a fare qualcosa
non sta fermo quelli parlere vorrei
parlare in questi diciassette minuti che
restano di qualcosa di diverso di
qualcosa che sta fuori da questo mondo
apparentemente lontano ma molto vicino a
noi stazione spaziale internazionale
una casa laboratorio che gira attorno
alla terra 28.000 chilometri all'ora
andiamo alla super che troviamo lassù
delle cose che non ci sono qui sulla
terra e paradossalmente possiamo cercare
scoprire cose che poi ci aiutano nella
vita di tutti i giorni e un posto
isolato confinato non è facile arrivarci
bisogna prendere un razzo non è che ci
sono poi così dietro l'angolo
è un po come avere una mini bomba
atomica di sotto che quando si accende
ti spara verso l'alto non ci vuole
moltissimo arrivare ai 400 km di quota
della stazione spaziale internazionale
diciamo 8 minuti e mezzo è come un
milano roma in 8 minuti e mezzo più o
meno dopo di che ti avvicini alla
stazione spaziale e finalmente si va
tutto bene di solito a va entri a far
parte di questo nucleo di extraterrestri
perché ci credo agli extraterrestri
avevamo noi questi extraterrestri che
sono lì ha sostanzialmente vivere e
lavorare in questa casa laboratorio e
qui cominciano subito i problemi perché
sostanzialmente tutti si è addestrato
per anni anni anche dieci anni e arrivi
su e non capisci più niente
scherzando si dice che il tuo quoziente
di intelligenza quando arrivi in orbita
si divide per tre perché sostanzialmente
il tuo cervello è impegnato a capire che
cosa sta succedendo
tu ti sei addestrato conosce esattamente
tutto quello che c'è qua attorno ma non
l'hai previsto il fatto che
non c'è più non senti più la forza di
gravità e quindi quando arrivi e cerchi
di mantenere i piedi verso il pavimento
quello che c'è scritto tech
scopri che non c'è c'è scritto da ekma
non è il pavimento quale ti è giusto e
lui sono io sono quegli altri laggiù in
fondo
boh e questo è un po quello che succede
quando siamo qua sulla terra abbiamo
dove abbiamo sentito anche prima la vita
è un continuo cambiamento
quando noi impariamo fare qualcosa e lo
facciamo bene e non facciamo nient'altro
ci siamo messi sulla via
dell'autodistruzione perché se la vita
cambia le cose cambiano quello che ti
sta attorno cambia e tu non cambi
perderà il lavoro non andrai avanti con
i qui è una scelta o diventi un
extraterrestre cerchi di capire che
cos'è hostel ii a farti mancare con le
cose che che non troverai mai
e inutile che ti metti a piangere che
non c'è la forza in grado rivoglio la
forza di gravità
sto mangiando le cose mi vola via tutto
non trovo più niente li cerco per terra
e non sono lì ecco inutile che fai
queste cose questo è quello che facciamo
normalmente nella vita non non cerchiamo
di cambiare questa inerzia che abbiamo
questo a questo cambiamento che poi di
fatto è cercare di capire come fare a
ottenere risultati in questa nuova
situazione non è semplice è difficile
quando non sai con cosa fare
guardare avanti esplorare e fare ma
quello che dobbiamo fare quindi quando
capisci che non è necessario tenere i
piedi verso la terra tenersi con le mani
lì per cercare di stare veramente lasci
andare tutto non trovi più niente e fai
come scott che alla leader tre mesi che
è già diventato extraterrestri livello
pacifico tranquillo lassù sembrava un
vampiro quando l'ho guardato no io
voglio dormire qua perché lì si dorme
meglio quando di fatto ho capito che era
esattamente la stessa cosa e quindi
questo questo cambiamento quest'inerzia
una cosa che dovremmo fare cambiare la
prospettiva invece di guardare di
continuare a guardare quello che ci
manca guardare a quello che c'è ma che
non scopriremo mai se non ci lavoreremo
la stazione spaziale è un posto dove si
lavora
ma dir la verità ti fanno lavorare dalle
sette e mezza di mattina alle sette e
mezza di sera all'orario di servizio fai
tutta una serie di attività di
esperimenti non sei tu che decidi e e
huston
ma la sera una sera chissà la sera quale
sarà quando non sei di servizio
mettiamola così abbiamo la capacità di
andare alla finestra e guardare di sotto
e di sotto si vedono delle cose
incredibili che cerchiamo di fotografare
una delle cose belle che possiamo fare e
vedi qualcosa come questa questa è
l'italia questa l'italia vista da so che
ho fotografato in 6 k la trovate questo
video dell'agenzia spaziale europea su
youtube
volendo e si vede l'italia come non la
vedi questa è passaggio in tempo reale
si vede fino in fondo lo dovrò affermare
tra poco ma vedete un po le le alpi qua
sopra che ci riparano dal dal nord dal
vento del nord
abbiamo il mar mediterraneo sotto
attorno che ci tempo era l'atmosfera
dovremo essere molto più freddi siamo 45
gradi piuttosto alti insomma un paese
veramente incredibilmente baciato dalla
natura e poi quando lo guardi con più
con più attenzione
rivedi di nuovo l'italia ma capita che
la vedi così e comincia a pensare hobbs
dove siamo noi in val padana e in val
padana
spesso e volentieri la situazione non è
non è delle più rosee difatti ogni tanto
si ferma la circolazione a milano ma
insomma è un po di più di piccola milano
e questo è quello che ti permette di
fare è guardare la stazione la terra
dalla stazione di vedere le cose
tirandosi indietro e abbracciare una
visione più completa e dico sempre
guardare la terra d'acqua da quaggiù è
come pretendere di vedere un ritratto
mettendo il naso appoggiato la tela vedo
qualche dettaglio ma non vedo questo
ritratto e questo è quello che ti dice
che ti dice le cose guardatele su dove
siamo qui bellaggio l'avete riconosciuto
il lago di como
siamo più o meno sotto questa nuvoletta
qua quindi va bene
ma noi non ci rendiamo conto di come la
natura non è esattamente come la
pensiamo noi questo è una serie di fiumi
in in argentina su di buenos aires ed è
interessante come tutte le volte che ci
passi sopra cambiano sono diversi
interessi perché i fiumi cercano di
andare dove
dove c'è meno resistenza questo lorino
coin in sudamerica
guardate questa foto dove si vede
sostanzialmente quante volte questo
fiume ha cambiato il suo corso nel nel
corso degli anni ma noi pensiamo che i
fiumi siano delle strutture che sono
ferme ma non è vero per niente questi si
muovono
se dovessimo guardare noi coi nostri
occhi da terrestri che dieci anni ci
sembrano tanti mille chilometri sembrano
tanti e li guardassimo con gli occhi
dell'extraterrestre vedremo che il fiumi
sono delle cose vive che si muovono in
continuazione
questo è il grand canyon che ha scavato
addirittura delle valli profonde due
chilometri ha portato via tutto quello
che c'era lì dentro e l'ha portato da
un'altra parte
questo il mississipi che nel 2011 ha
deciso di straripare ha mandato
sott'acqua tutta una serie di città e
uno di ciano mississipi straripa ma come
ma questo è quello che fanno i fiumi
quando si blocca da qualche da qualche
parte risalgono in sol altre dove e dove
costruiamo noi le città vicino ai fiumi
perché è molto più semplici serve
l'acqua ma non ci rendiamo conto che poi
i fiumi vanno fuori sempre una visione
generale il i caraibi poi quando li vai
a guardare da vicino vedi vedi le le
sabbie tirate vedi queste isolette vedi
questi spettacoli dalla su sembrano
casuali ma non sono poi così tanti
casuale qui siamo siamo in australia e
poi guardi qualcosa che abbiamo
cominciato a costruire dragando tutte le
sabbie e le barriere coralline perché
non ci basta abbiamo le città piena e
quindi costruiamo qualcosa qualcosa
fuori e non ci rendiamo conto che stiamo
cambiando totalmente la natura qua
attorno queste venezia venezia ogni
tanto va sott'acqua
non so se è stata una bella idea
costruire una città lì ma insomma
dovremo anche capire che prevenisse
bellissima c'era meno di una settimana
fa però insomma è un po e un po
problematica la situazione
questo è il vesuvio visto dallo spazio
ed è interessante come vedi tutta una
serie di di abitazioni lì attorno se fai
una foto di notte vedi dove esattamente
il vesuvio attorno ci sono un milione di
persone
se quello scoppia come ha fatto un po di
tempo fa qui c'è qualche problema
dovremo stare attenti
l'italia super luminosissima e sembra
che abbiamo elettricità gratis ce la
danno gratis
guardate un po la il resto dell'europa
quasi scura e poi arriva a milano
arriviamo noi che bruciamo energia senza
nessun problema eccolo qua a milano ha
visto dall'altra tra l'altro l'italia è
molto molto bella
ripeto è un paese incredibile visto
dalla su dovremo stare attenti però le
risorse che abbiamo
chiudo questa questo questo top con un
video un video che trovate su youtube
anche questo se fate una ricerca per the
sounds of silence odessa o silence nasa
trovate questo video pubblicato dalla
nasa l'abbiamo fatto con la nasa quando
eravamo in orbita io facevo un bel po di
fotografie di passaggi non fate qualcosa
come 500 mila
il russo faceva i dettagli e quindi
abbiamo messo assieme questo questa cosa
quindi volevo vederlo assieme a voi
perché vi fa vedere un po come come si
vede la terra dalla su e come diversa è
come dovremmo guardarla in un modo
diverso per per andare a questo action
per fare qualcosa per fare delle azioni
per stare attenti a cosa facciamo
questa è l'alba vista dallo spazio ci
vogliono circa 7 secondi per passare
dalla dalla notte al giorno
poi quando sette secondi dopo si accende
il mondo e vedi tutto bianco e blu
nuvole e oceani
poi ogni tanto qualche terra qualcosa da
veri ma è veramente difficile capire
anche dove sei o che cos'è c'è una
visione più completa qualcosa di strano
ogni tanto questo è l'ombra della luna
in un eclissi di sole che abbiamo
fotografato dallo spazio questa è
l'italia
e guardate l'africa dove hai dietro
l'angolo siamo proprio attaccati alla
fede questa e londra vista dallo spazio
questa è roma la stazione termini il
colosseo di notte si accendono le città
questa è la mecca in arabia saudita
i ghiacciai della patagonia
[Musica]
un'aurora australis
la luna con tutti i pianeti allineati in
quest'alba lunare di notte si accendono
le città questo è il nord degli stati
uniti siamo dappertutto come su un
albero di natale con un temporale la su
questo e washington negli stati uniti
questo e mosca 18 milioni di persone in
questo anello un atollo del pacifico
la grecia scura e l'africa bruciata dal
sole delle isole in egitto un lago in
australia una vista nel deserto del
sahara un impatto di un meteorite nel
sahara un vulcano nella camicetta
l'uragano arrivato contro huston quando
eravamo in orbita l'occhio di un tifone
è arrivato contro il giappone
i caraibi una macchia smeraldo sopra la
terra
[Musica]
qui volevo prenderli italia questa è la
spagna
l'africa al manda di terraneo arriva
l'italia arriva l'italia arriva lì un
nuvolone incredibile prega presule
puglia la puglia in africa nei deserti
non ci sono nuvole nilo cena israele
arabia saudita mar rosso
l'aurora boreale
[Musica]
un fiume nel madagascar rosso per le
deforestazioni una strada in un deserto
dell'iran
i deserti della namibia
new york
parigi
[Musica]
e ancora una visione d'insieme donne non
si vedono le nostre mini nazioni si vede
qualcosa ma ma non si vede molto che
alla fine c'è una c non delle
considerazioni da fare e lascia finire
questo questo questo video e poi
facciamo un paio di considerazioni in
chiusura
[Musica]
[Applauso]
vi dicevo mi dicevo che quando sei
lontano non vedi più i dettagli ma veri
qualcosa di insieme che è estremamente
importante uno guarda e vede qualche
qualche terra qualcosa ma di fatto
quello che succede è che noi siamo qua
sotto nelle nostre case nei nostri
giardini nelle nostre nostre città e non
ci rendiamo conto che siamo qua sotto e
abbiamo sopra di noi un muro un confine
che questo quando solo e se ne va resta
acceso per qualche minuto e l'atmosfera
quello è il nostro muro che ci divide
tra i nostri mini confini nostri mini
giardinetti e il vuoto dell'universo
se non ci fosse questo muro non ci
saremmo quindi dobbiamo stare attenti a
quello che facciamo ai nostri
giardinetti va bene ma anche a quel muro
perché senza quel muro non ci saremo
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]